[Music]
all right people
it is november 30th 2020 we're almost
into december
and i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
it was a long weekend holiday weekend
thanksgiving weekend
i know that most of you probably
committed several misdemeanors
and felonies by getting together with
family members
perhaps crossing state lines maybe even
sharing the spoon of a buffet style meal
so i know a lot of you are probably on
the run from the law right now
you're probably in a car you know cops
behind you
they're hunting us down they're coming
for us these moronic authoritarian
draconian laws that these dingbats
have tried to crush us with but i don't
think they're going to win
and in case you can't tell people i'm in
a very good mood this morning i am
completely
refreshed i needed a couple days just to
just to eat
basically sleep uh watch some tv and do
pretty much nothing else and that's
exactly what i did we
we did a little gardening around here we
we just ate
a obscene amount of food if you're not
following me
on on twitter or instagram or whatever
you can see the type of stuff that we're
cooking around here and i think we're to
work on a
cookbook as well we've sort of had an
idea for it for for quite some time um
so you can check out on you know
instagram reuben report and
twitter record all that stuff uh we did
a little gardening we watched airplane
david had never seen an airplane before
we watched airplane
and it's just like absolute perfection i
would say naked
guns still to me is the funniest movie
of all time but we did watch a little
airplane that was great
and oh and then we watch mandalorian and
i know you know i did a q a
over the last week or so and i said that
i wasn't loving mandalorian it just
didn't quite get me there
yet but finally the last two episodes
they're getting there and to see ahsoka
there and the way they're linking the
prequels
with the originals and now in the the
new well not the new universe but the
now universe i guess you could say i
thought that was pretty great too so
it's just i'm feeling good about life i
know the world is crazy
uh but uh i think i think some good
things are
on the horizon i think a lot of people
are really misjudging what's happening
in the world right now and we're seeing
a lot of people celebrate a little too
early oh and we're not even going to do
this story but i guess i should address
the fact oh no we are going to do this
story i was about to uh
to talk about biden's foot but we we are
we are doing biden's foot all right so
let's let's talk about lockdown
stupidity because uh here in los angeles
it it continues
to get worse and worse one day i'm just
going to be doing the show from
it'll literally just be a dark room i
will have nothing there'll just be a
spotlight on me
and nothing else because these lockdowns
they they just continue
so we'll start off with a a quote from
the los angeles
department of health and well here we go
as new covid 19 cases remain at alarming
levels and the number of people
hospitalized continues to increase a
temporary los angeles county health
officer order will be issued to require
additional
safety measures across sectors now
before i get into the
specifics of what they're asking us to
do and i assure you they're ridiculous
you're going to find out soon enough
i just wanted to point out that as far
as i know in the united states we don't
have
any hospitals that have been completely
overrun
we don't have any states that have been
completely destroyed
florida which has stayed open is not
somehow a million times worse
than california which has stayed closed
we don't see massive outbreaks in
homeless camp encampments now we got a
lot of homeless
encampments i went to home depot
yesterday i had to drive under a bridge
and there's literally now trolls under
the bridges because they all live under
the bridges now
and they have massive encampments
obviously no they're not doing
the things that would be best for
personal hygiene and wearing masks and
everything else
but we don't see massive outbreaks there
i passed i passed a uh i passed two
hospitals yesterday actually and they're
both
pretty much empty now again this isn't
to say that covet isn't real and we know
it's real and we know that 99 percent of
people roughly
survive it and we know we've got
vaccines coming out and everything else
and whether they're rushing out the
vaccines and whether you should take the
vaccine as a separate issue
but the point is that these insane
measures are just destroying people's
lives
and doing nothing else and i look
forward i i predicted this on twitter a
couple weeks ago but
i i really believe that 2021 is going to
be the year of the lawsuit
there are going to be so many class
action lawsuits and and personal
lawsuits
going after the crazy politicians who
manipulated science
and and did all sorts of things that
they constitutionally are not allowed to
do
but let's break down some of the numbers
and some of the specific things that
you're allowed to do
here in los angeles let's throw it up
this is very exciting
essential retail can be at 35
maximum occupancy now i don't know what
essential
retail is i mean i guess if you need
sneakers that would be essential
but like is buying like a hoodie not
essential or
like what is essential retail they don't
they never tell you it doesn't matter
but
okay 35 now where'd they come up with
that number now this is what i'm saying
about how none of this is based
in science like 35 at essential retail
that sounds like something like they put
some thought into it but why not 40
why not 45 i don't know non-essential
retail whatever that is
non-essential retail so is that a video
game store uh so that would be at 20
maximum occupancy all right you know
sounds sort of whatever uh includes
indoor malls at 20
i mean most indoor malls have been
failing for a long time they're usually
at 10
occupancy if you've been to a mall
lately so twenty percent they'd be
thrilled to have that
personal care services at uh can be at
twenty percent
max maximum occupancy so personal care i
assume that's like getting your nails
done getting your toe
toenails done maybe getting your hair
cut so okay 20
and i'm sure those businesses will
really thrive right
like those people who own those small
businesses that's going to really thrive
when
only one out of five of your little
chairs that you're at your nail salon or
your foot
specialist place when that uh when those
chairs are
uh all open four out of five are open
libraries can be at twenty percent
maximum occupancy okay
that whatever i mean again these numbers
they just make up these numbers
fitness centers operating indoors can be
at 50 percent
sorry outdoors can be at 50 percent
maximum occupancy
now remember most fitness places most
gyms your gym think about your gym
do they have an outdoor area the gym
that i used to go to i i went to equinox
i cancelled it but they had no outdoor
area and now it just sits there
absolutely empty good young healthy
vibrant people could be going to the gym
indoors
they could be taking their temperature
outside they could be washing things off
and sterilizing things but instead
they've
decided to destroy businesses like most
gyms don't have
just outdoor area for you to run around
and play in museums
galleries zoos and aquariums can be at
50 percent occupancy so what are they
gonna do with all the penguins
okay what are you gonna slaughter half
the penguins is that what
is that what we're doing now i mean
really is this we're gonna have a big
penguin roast at this point fifty 50
capacity i mean that again it just makes
no sense
museums galleries zoos and aquariums
let's try this
museums museums usually indoors mostly
indoors sometimes they have a little
outdoor area at a museum
galleries usually indoors okay fine
zoos outdoors right i've been to the la
zoo
here in la many times i've been to
safari park
uh which is the uh the san diego zoo
they've got the whole safari
you're in a big safari it's outdoors
can you be there aquariums outdoors for
the most part
the lizards you know they keep the
lizards indoors the point is none of
this makes sense why would a museum
that's indoors be at 50
capacity and an aquarium you see the
point uh and then here's my favorite
mini golf batting cages go cart racing
operating
outdoors can all be at 50 so
sure we've wrecked the livelihoods of
restauranteurs and
all sorts of people who opened little
shops and
whatever they wanted to do with their
lives but we're going to keep the
go-kart
thing going at 50 you know just 50
freaking percent
by the way this is all colored by the
fact that
right now they also are telling us that
you can't have anyone else in your home
that's right you are supposed to until
december 20th
so this is three weeks basically and
then by the way they'll roll that right
into christmas i mean they tried to
destroy thanksgiving and now they want
to destroy christmas these people are
evil do you get it yet
but they want nobody in your house so i
just want to be very clear about
something because you guys know i'm a
radical freedom extremist
i'm breaking the laws right now michael
will you please wave to the camera
okay that's one hand connor will you
wave to the
you see what's happening here people
i've got floating hands
in this room with me the room is i'd say
maybe ten by ten
there's at least two other hands in here
okay at least
what are you gonna come and get me
garcia you like oh screw you people
really
they're just awful but if you want to
know how awful they are i'd say
uh gavin newsom who is our ridiculous
governor here in california he hit
peak gavin newsom awfulness and then
kamala harris went into
peak kamala awfulness because they put
out these insane
tweets over the weekend because they
were talking about small
business saturday and here's the tweet
from gavin newsom i mean this is just
incredible
quote today is small business saturday
california is home to over 4 million
small businesses
this holiday season shop safe and shop
local
to help support our economy and the over
seven million workers
that help keep our small businesses
going okay
do you understand that gavin douchebag
newsom
is the one who has closed all of the
small businesses he has closed
all of the small shops all of the small
restaurants all of these things
and then he's also telling us that we
should shop there while he's got these
people with their restaurants closed
and boarded up the height of hypocrisy
this this guy is going to french laundry
the most
one of the most expensive restaurants in
the entire country i did this story last
week
he was with 22 people they were indoors
they didn't have
masks they spent fifteen thousand
dollars on booze fifteen thousand
dollars on booze that's about 750 bucks
a person on booze and then he has the
gall as they shut down and destroy lives
destroy your lives
they have the gall to tell you oh and
also shop at the small businesses only
the only thing is we closed all the
small businesses
right now literally i can go about two
miles away and go to target
target is open but if you were to go to
just the little store
just the little store that might have
some of the things that you might get at
target say
some holiday wrapping paper some gifs
trinkets whatever it is those stores are
closed and this
this num nut dingbat has the gall to say
this but then
the uh the presumed president-elect and
we'll get to the next story in a second
because i think she
thinks she's going to be president this
is from kamala she said
small businesses need our support now
more than ever before
this small business saturday and
throughout the holidays please shop
local and do your part to help the
backbone of our communities and our
economy
again democrats are the ones destroying
all of these businesses these people are
these people are liars and frauds
they are not good people if you don't
see it yet i i
if i could smack you i don't know that
we have the technology yet through the
youtube
but i would just whack you just a not a
not a full-on
bam but just like a you know like you
you wake up already
these these are not good people they
must be voted out and they have
they should have no authority to run
anyone's lives
and and by the way i'm just not
listening to any of their edicts like
i'm going to have people here look look
i got a floating hand watch this
floating hand
there's one floating hand can i get
another floating hand look at this i got
floating hands
like come and get me garcetti really
come and get me let's see what happens
man
ugh gross losers uh but it's not just
california
that's completely insane vermont is
actually uh potentially equally as
insane
because now they've got school children
ratting out
their parents yeah they literally want
children
to tell their teachers and
administrators at public schools
what the nature of their thanksgiving
holidays were i mean this is
absolutely insane this is this is a
story from the blaze the state of
vermont has announced that
school children and their parents will
be questioned
about the nature of their thanksgiving
gatherings after the kids returned to
school
and children and families that admit to
violating the state's rules
against celebrating with another
household will be required
to quarantine at home
do you see why we have a problem here
people
we are telling children that they should
rat
out on their family members did you
little johnny
celebrate thanksgiving with grandma sure
she only has a couple years to live and
maybe she didn't want to spend her last
years alone
in a dark room during thanksgiving she
wanted to take the risk
and be there with her family and you
could have socially distanced or done
whatever else
you wanted family but we're the
government and you better do what we say
god it's insane i mean kids ratting out
parents that's
what they want that's what they want and
by the way because
you know obviously i hit the democrats
on this a lot the governor of vermont is
a republican his name is phil
scott and he's the one that ordered the
vermont agency of education to execute
this
so most of these draconian laws most of
these ridiculous
rat on your neighbor were locking you
down we're destroying small businesses
while telling you to go to small
businesses
most of it's coming out of democrats but
phil scott you're the uh
you're the prime i'm trying you know
i've been saying f-bomb a lot on the
show lately because i've been
you know doing these special messages
and i know you guys enjoy them i
did a special message with my newsman
glasses i did a special message
to uh to gavin newsom and i think i did
to bill de blasio
and a lot of people are enjoying them
and then you know they get they pick up
some steam but i was trying to be nice
there
to phil to phil scott wasn't that what's
his name in the office
that was michael scott but you see the
same difference people
anyway i have the glasses here and i'm
thinking about doing one today but i'm
not i'm not sure yet because i'm trying
not to curse
too much but really like the idea of
children ratting
on their parents like how far away from
that to show me your papers right like
world war ii nazis
people just walking down the street show
me your papers or we're gonna take you
away it's just
it's just crazy um all right well
speaking of crazy
there's a 78 year old man who is the
presumed president-elect although i'm
pretty sure it ain't going to happen
we'll we'll see about that
there's a lot of stuff going on there
that the mainstream's not not talking
about
not not talking about they're not
talking about it um
but we got this 78 year old guy with
dementia and then on
saturday apparently he broke his foot he
fractured his foot while playing with
his dog now normally
uh you would think a 78 year old man
with a broken foot in dementia maybe he
shouldn't be the leader of the free
world but
let's put that aside for a sec here's
abc news
they said after initial x-rays were
reassuring
a follow-up ct scan showed that
president-elect joe biden has hairline
fractures
in his foot following a fall this
weekend his doctor said biden will
likely need to wear a walking boot
for several weeks you know the boot you
know that boot you see these people with
the boot i don't know
i laugh every time i see the boot
something about that boot
just seems very funny to me but okay
it's already started with joe biden it's
like this man
if if he is sworn in on january 20th
which again i'm still
not convinced is going to happen but if
he is sworn in on january 20th
the idea that he is going to be
president for four years till he's 82
years old he obviously has the
beginnings of dementia he now has a
broken
foot and he's going to be in a boot and
a broken foot you know what happens
after the broken foot people it's the
broken hip
and you know what happens to elderly
people once they break the hip
okay we all know what this thing looks
like like this is
just the i don't know if they pushed him
i'm not you know i'm not saying any of
that happened let's just say he tripped
over the dog or something happened with
the dog
but this guy is not ready is not
it's not ready that's not the right word
he is not fit
to be president of the united states and
this is just in a way
you think his team has got to be
thrilled right now because they're like
oh now we have the perfect excuse to
never get him out there right
we never have to get him out because we
don't want him to be seen in the boot
limping like like a lame dog right so
instead we're just gonna
hide him and we'll let kamala do all the
talking and man she
you know she is licking her chops
just waiting for that 25th amendment to
be
called out and go i'm taken over but i
assure you people if biden is sworn in
on january you know what here we go i'm
going to make a bold statement
michael come to make a bold statement
today bold statement here we go if joe
biden
is sworn in on january 20th 2021
and he completes a four-year term
actually completes a four-year term
i will retire i will retire at the end
of that term that will be it i will
disappear
in just over four years four years in
about a month and a half
that'll be it that's how convinced i
will just disappear
from public life altogether i will
delete all of my accounts
and then you'll never hear from me again
that's how convinced i am
that it ain't gonna happen he will not
be president for four years he either
won't be president at all
because of the the election fraud and
all that kind of stuff
um which by the way is gaining momentum
we're not even really covering it that
much today but it is actually gaining
momentum and giuliani was at a hearing
in arizona today
they found some really bizarre stuff
with these mid
you know these late night 1 a.m to 6 a.m
vote dumps
i think in pennsylvania rand paul was
tweeting about it this morning
i mean there's just some stuff going on
but i do not think that one way or
another joe biden will not be president
for four years anyway so he's got a
broken foot on top of everything else
and then i saw this clip this weekend
you know i try not to tweet on the
weekends but then
you know sometimes i accidentally get on
there literally accidentally like you
just open up my phone and my finger just
goes to it i'm like ah i'm in there
or sometimes people send me some things
but i thought this was just spectacular
because
this is four years ago basically to the
day
this is right after donald trump was
elected president
and the russians were involved in the
whole thing and it was very bad
uh and he was on chris hayes's show on
msnbc now first when you see this clip
chris hayes to me is a five-year-old
who's dressed up like an adult
with his fancy glasses to look like he's
an important person who knows what he's
talking about
but they talk about the the wonderful
ways that they could overthrow
the election of donald trump and i
thought it would be worth showing you to
when these people
show when they now tell you oh no no no
no there's nothing
we can do and you must obey the results
of the election but they were singing a
different tune four years ago
here's the clip from msnbc
you think there are people who are
pushing very hard who think that
because of some of the constitutional
perils of the emoluments clause
uh because of the popular vote margin
because of um
a fundamentals they think threat to
liberal democracy that that elector
should be persuaded and pressured on
monday
to to part with what their pledges and
vote and vote against donald trump yes
they absolutely should do that
absolutely
i believe right now that there are
electors they only need 38 of them
who have a conscience or who are worried
about a man who won't attend the daily
security briefings
who uh who we now know russia was trying
to help
get elected i mean can you imagine this
if you or i have been running for office
and they
they show that the iranians were somehow
involved in helping you
or me get elected what would happen to
you or me
chris i'm just curious what would happen
i think it would be a totally ch
all right people i'm as serious as those
two i've got thick grim glasses on so
you know what i'm about to say
has a lot of weight okay um yeah what is
what is michael moore michael moore ugh
go to the gym
take a couple days off bread for god's
sakes um
he says electors with a conscience that
they're the ones that are supposed to
flip
the election and he obviously got help
from the russians god these people are
absolutely patently absurd
patently absurd everything they said
four years ago is now the reverse
of what they're saying now and that
again is why you really shouldn't be for
a team in and of itself because then
you're just going to flip
constantly you should try to have some
basic set of principles that you can
apply
and then you go oh well maybe i want to
scale back power
this is what i tell you guys all the
time right and i'm a guy with thick rim
glasses so you know i know what i'm
talking about
what you want to do in a healthy society
is scale back the power
so that when the guy who's the real bad
guy gets in
he can't do that much bad and when the
guy who you like
your good guy right your hero when he
gets in the trade-off is he can't do
everything you want and that allows us
to have that healthy tension
between conservative and liberal and
left-right and red blue democrat
republican
and the rest of it um i'll take the
glasses off for the rest of this
anyway i thought it was worth uh it was
worth showing you guys that there is
just
such a series of of stupid things
happening
um but that's what we're here for that's
what we're here for by the way i wasn't
even gonna do a show today uh because we
just uh we hired our new director connor
and he's here
in person for the first time so i know
over the last couple weeks we've had a
couple little technical glitches we've
been doing a lot of stuff on the fly and
everything else but we've now got
our full team here in los angeles and
uh you know what let's just show them
the floating hands one more time just to
prove i'm here
with human beings okay i know i'm gonna
i'm gonna
i'm racking up fines left and right over
here real people
in this room we're all gonna be okay
we're making decisions
for ourselves i think we're going to go
out for a little while because
we're going to go out for lunch we can't
go out for lunch we're going to sit
outside for lunch that's what we're
going to do today
uh all right guys uh we're back five
days a week
this week originally as i said i was
gonna only plan to do this show three
days a week
but the world just won't let me have a
day by the way we posted
uh part one of my new interview with
douglas murray douglas is basically
the clearest thinker around uh highly
recommend
you watch it i got his take on
everything happening in america he was
in america
actually stayed with us for a couple
days uh here at the house
but he was in america where he he went
to trump rallies he traveled with
antifa he was at some of the election
stuff
and got you know as someone from the uk
got just like an insider's view of
america so we talk about that
he also opines on this story that you
probably heard
about penguin random house which is my
publishing company by the way
they're the people that publish don't
burn this book the canadian
imprint uh they were they were having
all sorts of problems because
jordan peterson's new book is coming out
and some of the some of the children who
work there were very upset and they were
crying because jordan's a white
supremacist and the rest of it which of
course
is the reverse of truth and it shouldn't
matter uh
whether whether an author is
controversial or not because it's about
how many books can this person sell and
everything else so we get his feelings
on that
and much more so clip one is up and then
the rest will be out throughout the week
and of course the full episode
is up on reubenreport.com already don't
forget to subscribe to the channel here
we got a busy day hope you're good
and and i just one last thing i think
everything's gonna be okay
i can't really explain why but i i sense
something good this week
today's monday by the time i do this
show on friday i think we're gonna have
some good news people that's the day of
ruben prediction
i've never been wrong before so we'll
see what happens alright
that's it see you tomorrow